So viel steht fest der sommer
2018 war bisher an normal warm jetzt sagt eine neue prognose voraus das ist auch in den nächsten vier jahren
solche hitze extreme geben wird und zwar gehäuft denn zur globalen klimaerwärmung
kommt eine natürliche klimaschwankungen dazu die zeit zu führen könnte dass sich die erde in den nächsten fünf jahren noch stärker
erwärmen wird als bisher vorausgesagt
wie das
internationale forschungsteam auf diese prognose kommt und was wir wirklich in den kommenden jahren zu erwarten haben das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt in
kriegs um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Jede wird immer wärmer dieser trend ist klar ebenso klar ist dass wir menschen einen großteil dazu
beitragen denn durch unsere co2 emissionen heizen wir dem klimawandel
so richtig ein fast jedes jahr werden neue klima rekorde erreicht und wenn der extreme wie dürren und
starkregen häufen sich die hitzewelle in diesem sommer ist auch ein beispiel dafür wir haben darüber berichtet aber
forschungsteams weltweit sind sich auch einig darüber dass nicht alle veränderungen des klimas auf uns menschen
zurückzuführen sind denn das klimasystem der erde ist extrem komplex und immer wieder mal treten
natürliche schwankungen auf das wetterphänomen el niño ist ein beispiel dafür aber es gibt noch zahlreiche weitere
die wir mit unserem klima modell nur schlecht vorhersagen bzw überhaupt erfassen können genau dieses problem ist ein
internationales forschungsteam aus frankreich und großbritannien jetzt angegangen sie haben ein neues statistisches modell
entwickelt das genau solche schwankungen vorhersagen soll das besondere dabei ist das modell ist lernfähig anders als
klimasimulationen die wir bislang kennen als datengrundlage wurden die veränderungen der globalen mitteltemperatur
'nen und der meeresoberfläche vom zwanzigster und dem beginnenden
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert zu grunde gelegt den zug kamen die daten aus zehn verschiedenen klimasimulationen
das modell namens pro gast suchte in diesem datenwust gezielt nach klimadaten die der aktuellen situation
eine daraus ermittelte es die wahrscheinlichkeit für eine bestimmte klimaentwicklung
von dem ergebnis war das forschungsteam selbst äußerst überrascht denn zur probe hatten sie es zunächst
einmal eine prognose für die vergangenheit erstellen lassen nämlich für die entwicklung des klimas in den letzten 20 jahren
und das modell
präsentierte sich als äußerst treffsicher und bildeten die jüngste klimaentwicklung sehr gut ab das ziel des forschungsteams aber war als
klimaschwankungen zum
prognostizieren zum
vorauszusagen die in den nächsten 15 jahren stattfinden werden zudem sollten auch deren schwankungen auf das klima im großen und ganzen
versackt gemacht werden dazu das forschungsteam die verlässlichkeit von pro card für die jährlichen globalen
mitteltemperaturen in zeiten da waren von einem bis fünf jahren ist nahezu perfekt
und so konnten die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler dann auch guten gewissens das neu entwickelte modell nutzen um ihre
eigentliche prognose zu erstellen die konkrete grundfrage hier lautete wie werden die natürlichen schwankungen die globalen mittel
temperaturen und die meeresoberfläche
temperatur von
2018 bis
beeinflussen und das ergebnis ist eindeutig kurz gesagt würde es demnach noch bis 2022
eine warmzeit geben konkret wird bis dahin ein natürlicher
klimatrend die menschengemachte erderwärmung
verstärken das forschungsteam vermutet einen noch stärkeren
temperaturanstieg als es die klimamodelle bislang vorhergesagt haben die mitteltemperatur
wird schon bis 2019 zusätzlich um 0,03 grad ansteigen und die meerestemperaturen um
0.07 grad so das ergebnis des modells dazu das forschungsteam die kommende wahlperiode ist zudem mit einer erhöhten wahrscheinlichkeit
für besonders hohe bis extreme temperaturen verbunden die wahrscheinlichkeit für so genannte marine hitzewellen sei bis zum jahr 2022
sogar um bis zu
400 prozent höher
das sind hitze schübe in den weltmeeren die schon bei einem anstieg von wenigen graden für einige bewohner wie etwa korallen oder seetang
tödlich sein können wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollt auch extra videos und livestreams
nicht dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal und nimmt auch noch ein paar privilegien mit außerdem unterstützt sie uns mit einem kleinen betrag
einfach auf mitglied werden klicken direkt hier unter dem video einen riesen
die schon mitglied geworden sind das macht uns etwas unabhängiger von den schwankenden werbeeinnahmen
wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige abo boxer auf youtube und er verpasst kein video einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks und social media abonnieren dafür jeglichen aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken hitze und klimawandel heißt zeit bedroht erde bis dann
bleibt